hello and welcome to this video playing
roomie lives here with black and okay so
this is where you have four four losses
in a row and then I get this oh my god i
get this opening which is the most
boring ever it's really extremely boring
okay maybe can insert some life into
this should be six keeping some pieces
on the board yeah okay this is this is
now okay in terms of boring boringness
said a word botanist I think it's
botanist okay anyway I'm kind of okay
with this position let's see what roomie
who's living apparently em it's coming
up with hey one soon either fianchetto
which is not quite clear to me what this
is doing one wants to play Bishop e3 I
mean my night belongs to you six this is
why I'm doing this regrouping straight
away looking at the d4 square looking at
the f4 square back to you too okay so
yeah maybe just cancel
so night f-4s re Knight d4 he wants to
trade this right away okay
don't mind that gives black pretty
substantial space advantage night f5
okay that I did not really have on the
radar I thought that this was when he
has nothing developed nothing at all so
494 rather but ok it doesn't feel like I
can I can refute it immediately maybe I
maybe there are some ideas ok let's see
if I go Queen f6 here I don't know this
could be it too much a little bit too
much we should be for it's also
interesting hey this is actually
probably good yeah because it if he
moves the bishop now I trade and play
Queen f6 this should be should be really
good for black check then g4 that's hard
to believe of course plays at own soul
rook e8 you will play every year
probably
I can go afford III in this position of
this kind of thing but I'm not sure this
could be too brutal but maybe it's right
let's try it just playing further
playing for that see porn
and I know no key 8 is a bit lame it's a
bit lame yeah maybe still okay three
tries to play probably I guess maybe a
4m stuff like that
oh my god
if you take such cutesy to doesn't quite
work but I just wanted to play Queen
deform
okay so yeah clingy form isn't quincy
three now the moves let's try i can take
this now why did I take it actually I
could I could have done without taking
and anyway it's still kind of
interesting so you know I can do this
right
I mean it's kind of funky because he has
some ponds himself but he doesn't have
roots III which is the most important
thing he has to play up t to now I don't
think it it helps at the end so check
check see
time warning what a crazy game I really
should be okay now this is I can just
take it right I mean okay I mean I'm
winning now so be too probably I might
just just keep all the pots I mean why
give any pawn away here let's use listen
just push stuff
if I just queen what's the deal see it
check let's don't check in right yep no
chicken quite resigned wow wow wow I old
extremely scary yeah okay so let's let's
start right right here in the opening I
was really council tried that night at
five should be playable yeah so I played
the wrong move ordered I am okay I
should play Queen f6 this was my initial
idea because he had fought Queen g4 and
then II for this is now given by the
engineer this is the this is the point
yeah I saw that but I thought that
Bishop before we'll chat even more
convincing chat some way because now g4
is fourth and I couldn't believe in that
move at all but maybe it is not that bad
it's not that bad I mean it looks
terrible but maybe it's okay if he gets
castles and f3 in this is why I play d4
immediately trying to force the foursome
matter but can it just leads to this is
very unclear have no idea what's going
on to be honest the computer likes white
which is it doesn't surprise me I think
it's possible that he's better he's
better him yeah now before how it gets
extremely murky ok this am and he also
could have taken Young in this case I'm
I'm not quite sure what I'm doing twin
c2 doesn't work I was thinking just 24
again but of course he he he SD 5 and
this is probably a better
version of the game as there is no be
porn anymore that's probably just very
good for wine okay this and now Queen D
for gets interesting you cannot do this
you know this is great for black yang
with the check the two looks are really
extremely dangerous here with the open
King seems to win even I didn't
calculate but this should should be good
yeah now no black wins I had problem he
has to avoid this c4 c4 stuff snow the
pawns are check by far too dangerous I
played it played it safe but say that's
not bad check yeah man she is running
out of chicks it was a weird game but
I'm happy to stop the losing streak for
the row is pretty awful okay thanks for
watching